all right I have another question yeah I
have question from Natalie Dingle
approximately how many stars are born
and dying each day I'm assuming birthday
and not somebody else's day earth right
but of course other planets have days
yes in fact Venus's day is longer than
its year just chill on that one for a
bit so Leanne's face just scrunched up
in a yeah yeah Venus the day is last
longer than yet but we'll get back to
that if we go there so and where was i
before i distracted myself how many
started to warn you today so you can do
what's called a back-of-the-envelope
calculation really ready all right our
galaxy has about just say 100 billion
stars okay and the universe has been
around for about 10 billion years with
back-of-the-envelope means you change
the number to make the math easy but
you're answering my taxes all so but
your answer will be approximately
correct and later on you could put the
exact number in if you want the exact
answer so say we have about 100 billion
stars and the universe the galaxy has
been out for ten billion years okay so
we have a hundred billion stars we've
been around for ten billion years that
means the galaxy makes ten stars a year
that's an average yeah on average that's
right if it made ten stars a year
throughout this whole life we'd have 100
billion stars over the 10 billion years
that's how that works
so it makes about ten stars a year so
that's about one a month and so we don't
quite make a star a day on average about
one a month we could live with that
however that's not actually how stars
are born they weren't episodically in
stars in stellar nurseries where
thousands of stars are born all at the
same time so if you were a planet in
orbit around one of those stars you'll
see stars lighting up daily as they are
born
well not daily but frequently
yeah a reminder that we had the stars
first before there are Hollywood stars